hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about the sorting algorithms but
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
we will begin our session with bubble
sort bubble sort is majorly used for
teaching the basics of sorting
algorithms then we will discuss the
binary search algorithm which is usually
used for searching a large data set
after that we will dive into the bfs
algorithm the bfs or breadth first
search algorithm is used for gps
navigation then we will discuss the
depth first search or dfs algorithm dfs
algorithm is typically used for job
scheduling after that we will discuss
the linear search algorithm this type of
algorithm can be used for both
one-dimensional and two-dimensional
array sorting
post that we will discuss the bucket
sort algorithm bucket sort works on the
divide and conquer strategy then we will
introduce you to the counting sort
algorithm a special sorting algorithm
that does not involve any comparisons
after that we will dive into the radix
sort algorithm radix sort algorithm is
used for sorting data on each node of a
multiprocessor then we will discuss the
heap sort algorithm this algorithm is
beneficial in sorting priority queues
then we will discuss the merge sort
merge sort algorithm is commonly used to
sort large databases after that we will
discuss the quick sort algorithm quick
sort is typically used in commercial
computing after that we will discuss the
selection sort algorithm in selection
sort algorithm the number of swaps
included are limited to as least as
possible post that we will discuss shell
sort algorithm this algorithm has higher
cache miss ratio
finally we will discuss the greedy
algorithm this algorithm can implement
minimum spanning trees so this is the
agenda for today's discussion i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
let's get started with the first one
let's try to understand what is a bubble
sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm is one of the
fundamental and simplest forms of
algorithm used to sort a collection of
elements the collection of elements can
be either a set of numbers or characters
the control iterates through a sequence
of numeric or character type elements in
the bubble sort algorithm and rearranges
them into ascending or descending order
the bubble sort algorithm rearranges one
element at a time
the bubble set algorithm is also known
as the sinking algorithm
here we have some random distributed
elements which are 30
10
20
50 and 40 and after performing the
bubbles out algorithm all the elements
are sorted as 10
20 40 and 50.
so how is it done
we will see in the next segment where we
will understand the working
terminologies of bubble sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm will not get
implemented on the entire array in one
go instead it compares two adjacent
pairs of elements in an array if the
elements are not in the correct order
then they are swapped so the largest of
the two moves towards the right and this
process continues until the most
significant element or bubble is moved
towards the highest position
after the first process is finished the
search for the next most significant
object starts
and the swapping continues until the
whole array is in correct order this
process is employed when you want to
arrange the elements in ascending order
to understand the logic in a better way
let's go through an example
the example on my screen consists of
five elements according to the bubble
sort algorithm logic we need four
iterations to sort all the elements in
the ascending order or in descending
order the elements in the array are as
follows they are 3
8 4 2 and 12. so in this array the index
begins with 0 and ends with 4
and each time the bubble sort algorithm
goes through the data element list and
it is known as a pass
let us analyze the total number of
comparisons required to sort the array
in the correct order according to the
formula
if n is the total number of elements in
an array then the total number of
comparisons needed to sort the entire
array can be calculated by a simple
formula shown on my screen that is n
is equals to n minus 1.
so in this scenario we need 5 minus 1
that is 4 comparisons or passes to sort
the entire array in the first pass there
are four steps
let us select the first two elements
that is three and eight according to the
requirement we need to sort this array
in the ascending order hence when we
compare 3 and 8 clearly we get 3 as the
least number so we do not need to swap
them
next is the step 2. comparing the second
and third elements which are 8 and 4.
here we need to swap these two elements
because
8 is always greater than 4 and it
requires placing the elements in the
ascending order
now moving ahead we have step three
moving on to the third and fourth
elements which are eight and two and
here again we need to swap eight with
two because eight is greater than two
and in the step four we have we have the
last elements which are 8 and 12. there
is no need to swap because 8 is already
less than 12 so you can see it clearly
so now we enter into past 2 and in past
2 we need 3 steps
so the first step in the second pass let
us select the first two elements which
are three and four
no swapping is necessary as they are
already in order
next we have step two
in step two we need to select the
elements two and four as you can see two
is always less than four so there is no
swapping required
next we have step three in step three we
need to compare the elements four and 8
and here we may not need any switching
because 4 is already less than 8. now
here you can see that we are not
comparing 8 and 12 because the last
element is already sorted now we have
come to the last pass
and here there is only one step the step
is to compare the first two elements 2
and 3 and then swap them as 3 is greater
than 2. now the array is finally sorted
and we do not need to do any more
comparisons
after understanding the working process
of the bubble sort algorithm we will see
its pseudo code in this pseudo code
there is a function named as bubble sort
the bubble sort function includes an
array of collections of sortable
elements let us consider n as the length
of the array after that we have to
repeat comparisons for the first element
to the last element of the array if the
first element is greater than its next
consecutive element then we must swap
both the elements and place them
correctly we do not need to switch after
closing this repeated statement and
getting out of the loop this bubble sort
function will end after understanding
the pseudo code of the bubble sort
algorithm let's learn about the
optimized bubble sort algorithm so we
can optimize the algorithms in a loop by
programming it to avoid the comparison
at n minus 1 position after every
iteration since the nth element is
already sorted in the previous iteration
more generally
more than one element may be placed in
their final position on a single pass
all the elements after the last swap are
sorted in every pass and do not need to
be rechecked optimized bubble sort
algorithm allows skipping over many
elements this results in a worst case
that is 50 improvement in comparison
count and adds little complexity because
of the new code sub sums the swapped
variable
next we will learn variations of the
bubble sort algorithm so there are two
variations of the bubble sort algorithm
they are
odd even sort and cocktail shaker so odd
even sort is a parallel version of
bubble sword for the message passing
system
whereas cocktail shaker is a sort of
bi-directional bubble sort that first
goes from beginning to the end and ends
to the beginning after knowing the
variation of the bubble sort algorithm
now we will see the complexity of bubble
sort algorithm
so the best case of the bubble sort
algorithm is big o of n where n is the
number of elements being sorted and
worst and average cases of the bubble
set algorithm are big o of n into n and
lastly the space complexity of the
bubble sort algorithm is big of 1. here
n is the number of data elements being
sorted let us understand when this
complexity occurs the best case of
bubble sort algorithm is o of n which
occurs at all the data elements in an
array are already sorted here we have an
example with some data elements in an
array which are already sorted that is
10 20 30 40 and 50.
next talking about the average and worst
case the worst case and average case of
the bubble set algorithm is o of n to
the power 2 that is n squared or n into
n it occurs when all the data elements
in an array are reversely sorted again
we have an example that consists of data
elements that are reversely sorted that
are 50 40 30 20 and 10 in an array
lastly we have space complexity the
space complexity of bubble sort
algorithm is o of one because only one
additional variable is required to
implement bubble sort algorithm that is
temporary variable we came to the last
topic where we will understand four main
applications of bubble sort algorithm
first application of bubble sort
algorithm states that this sorting
technique is used to sort the elements
in a specific order the bubble sort
algorithm uses less storage and is the
second application of bubble sort
algorithm third the real-life
application states that the bubble sort
algorithm is used to store the students
based on their height in a line
lastly bubble sort is used to create a
stack pile up the elements based on
their height after covering all the
bubble sort algorithm topics we will now
see a practical demonstration of bubble
sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
bubble sort algorithm so let us get
started with the code in this code at
the first position we have some header
files that is standard input output
standard library etc
after that we will define the main
function in the main function we will
declare an array with maximum size of
50. so here you can see that we have the
first array variable that size is 50.
size will be defined by declaration only
because we cannot change the array size
in the runtime after that we will
declare four variables that is a
b
num and temp
none variable will store the number of
elements of an array after that we will
ask the user how many elements are
required for the array using printf
function
so here is the printf function where we
will be asking the
user to enter the number of elements in
an array and the user will enter the
elements and this will be done using
scanf function then finally we will
print all the elements that the user
wants to store in an array using another
printf function
we will have three loops firstly there
will be a loop from the first element to
the last element of the array so this is
the first for loop we need then second
the for loop will use the variable a for
the rotation purpose as we know rotation
equal to number of elements minus 1 so
it will make a loop from index 0 to
number minus 1.
the last loop is used for how many
passes will be required for the
implementation and we already pass
equally to the number of elements minus
number of rotations minus 1 so there is
the loop from index 0 to number minus a
minus 1 then there will be the if
condition stating that if the first
element of an array at index b is
greater than the element at the index b
plus 1 then we will make swap then we
will come out of the loop and we will
print all the array elements after
performing the bubble sort algorithm now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed now let us enter
the number of elements let me choose 5.
now let us enter the elements in a
random order
so this was the array input 3 2 4 1 and
5 and here after executing the bubble
sort algorithm we have the sorted array
that is 1 2 3 4 and 5.
binary search tree is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
keys in binary search tree
so during search if the key is found
then the corresponding value
will be retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up
the left subtree of a node contains only
nodes with keys lesser than the parent
node
next up
the right subtree of a node contains
only nodes that are greater than the
parent node
the left and the right subtree each must
also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a
binary search tree
first up
insertion last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node in a such a way so
that we obey binary search tree rules
that is the
new node should be either less than the
parent node if it's a it's on the left
subtree or if it's on the right subtree
it should be greater than the parent
node let's execute this in the code
editor
we will start by creating a class for
the binary search tree
so class
pst
hint data
and bst pointers
left
comma
right
next we will define some functions
publicly
public
first default constructor
and a parameterized constructor
a function to insert the value
and a function to traverse the node
now let's write default constructors
definition
so bst
pst
now let's write the parameterized
constructor's definition
bst
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left is equals to null
and
right
equals to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so bst
star
root
comma
end
value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
new
est
value
otherwise we will insert the data so if
the
value
is greater than
root
tata
and
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so
root
right
is equals to
insert
root
right
comma
value
else
else the value should be inserted in the
left
side
so root
left
is equals to
insert
root
left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the traverse function
so void
est
purpose
if
root
and we will return
otherwise we will first traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
then we will traverse
the right
root
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
bst
b
comma
star root
is equals to
null
root
is equals to
b dot insert
root
comma
50
e dot
insert
to
root comma 10
b dot insert
gonna be root comma
30
d dot insert
root
comma 50.
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
60
a dot insert
root
comma
plus is 20.
let's try to traverse this
so b dot
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right subtree should be greater than
the parent node
let's try these in the correlator
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure so
struct
node
and
right
now we will create a utility function to
create a new binary search tree node so
struct
node
star
new node
and
item
am
equals to
product
size of
next
amp will be assigned the key
is equals to item
amp
left
equals to null
and
stamp
right
is equals to
now let's write
a function to traverse the tree
traverse
product
node
star
route
so if
root
is equal to null
traverse
root
left
see out
root
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
substruct
node
comma
and
key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
otherwise
we will recur down the tree so if
e
is less than
a node key
then we will
insert in the left subtree so node
left
is equals to insert
mode
left
comma
key
else
node right
would be inserting
e
now let's return the note
now we have given a non-empty binary
search tree
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tray
so
we will start
extract
star
men
value
node
product
out star mode
product
node
start
current
is equal to node
so we will loop down to find the
leftmost leaf
so
while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
current
product
delete
node
note star
loop
comma
and
key
f
root
equals to null
return
route
now if the key to be related is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check
if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
it will be equals to
delete
node
root
left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right subtree so else
if
e
is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma key
if
roots
dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
and return
else
if
root
that
equals to null
then struct
node
is equals to
root
right
and free
root
return
else if
roots
right
is equals null
then struck
out star
temp
is equals to root
free
route
return
stamp
now note with the two children
get the in order successor
smallest in the right subtree
so struct
node star
temp
is equals to
min value
node
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the inorder successor
so root
right
first to
delete node
root
right
comma
temp
now we will return
root
now let's write the main block
will start with an empty tree
note star
root
is equals to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root comma
two
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
five
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
three
root
is equals to insert
root
comma four
root
is equals to
insert
root
comma 7
and root
equals to insert
root comma
6.
let's try to traverse this so c out
traversal
of
the given
i was
root
now first we will delete a value see out
delete
two
our root is equals to
delete
node
root comma
two
c out
traversal
after
deleting
traverse
route
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted
to and traverse the tree again
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first of left side notes are always
lesser than the parents node and the
right side node are always more than the
parent node
next it is easier to search and sort
elements in a binary search tree
finally a binary search tree offers
faster insertion and deletion operations
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let us try to understand breadth
first search algorithm breadth first
search algorithm which begins by
traversing the root node and then moves
on to all the other nearby nodes the
breadth first search approach repeats
the procedure for all the nodes until
the desired node is found
the queue data structure is the data
structure that is used for breadth first
search algorithm
for a better understanding we look at an
example of breadth first search
algorithm the blue color indicates that
the note has been already explored while
the pink color indicates that the node
has not been explored yet or visited yet
next we'll have our output we will use a
queue data structure to keep track of
all the nodes visited and all the nodes
that are unvisited
so to begin let's look at the algorithm
as a result we'll have node a which is
added to the output and marked as
visited
we must verify all the unvisited
addition nodes of a that is node b and
node c and add b and c nodes to the
output and enqueue to the queue
according to the breadth first search
algorithm
then
we'll look at any node between b and c
we'll start with node b node d is
unvisited adjacent to node b so we'll
add node d to the output and q and since
node b is now being visited will dequeue
it
when it goes to node b the next
unvisited node is node e add node e to
the output and enqueue to the dq once
node d has completed its traversal dq
from the queue
now in the case of node e the adjacent
node is node c
which is already visited thus we will
dequeue node c from the queue
now that the pointer is pointing to node
c and node f is the next unvisited node
after the node c we will set node f to
output and q
here the pointer leads to node f which
has no unvisited adjacent nodes so we
will dequeue f from the queue and q is
empty so we'll come to the hold here
here's what we got that is a b c d e and
f
after understanding all the theoretical
aspects of bfs algorithm let's look at
the code of bfs algorithm in c
programming language
now we are on the practical mode on my
screen you can see an example for bfs
algorithm
we have declared a two dimensional array
with maximum row and column size of 10
and two arrays the first one is a square
of a maximum size of 10 and second one
which is a visited that stores the
maximum size of 10 as well
some variables n i j and finally we
declared front which is initialized with
0 and rare variables which is
initialized with -1
we perform a loop from index 1 to the
size of an array visited in this
function with the condition that if
2-dimensional array of column 1 and
visited array of index is not one we
initialize variable i to the front of
the queue then one is set as the front
of the queue index of the visited array
and we use the breadth first search
function
with the vertex as the front of the
queue until front is less than or equal
to rare then we enter the main function
where we define the variable x that
stores the graphs vertex and then we use
the printf function to enter the number
of vertex that will be stored in
variable n then we perform loop from
index 1 to queue size and visited array
in which we initialize 0 to the queue
and index 1 with the visited array then
after that we'll enter the graph value
in the form of matrix of two dimensional
array by performing the loop with two
variables
i for the graph row and j for the graph
column
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x and we call the
breadth first search function or method
which takes a vertex x as parameter and
we print which nodes are reachable by
looping from index 1 to the size of the
visited array if index 1 of the array is
visited otherwise breadth first search
is not possible so this was the
explanation of the program now let's try
to execute and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully compiled and now it's
asking for the input now it is asking
for the number of vertices let's enter
the number of vertices as three
now it is asking for us to enter the
input in the form of matrix
so the first row will be one
two
and three so these are the first rows
the next rows will be two
three
and four
so the last row elements are three four
and 5.
so we have successfully given all the
three rows of elements now let us select
the source node so the source node would
be 2. now all the nodes that are
reachable from the source node 2 are 1 2
and 3.
so there you go that's how you implement
the breadth first search algorithm
so what is a depth first search
so basically a depth first search is an
algorithm for traversing or searching
the tree or graph data structures the
algorithm starts at the root node
selecting some arbitrary node as the
root node in case of graph and x plots
as far as possible along each branch
before backtracking
so dfs starts with the initial node of
the graph then goes deeper until it
finds the goal nodes or the leaf nodes
or the nodes that have no children that
is the end part here you can see four
and seven are the leaf nodes so the
depth first search algorithm runs till
the end of all the nodes that is 8 10
all these are the
leaf nodes or the last gold nodes
in dfs the backtracking starts once all
the nodes are explored
and the dfs algorithm uses stack data
structure for its traversal now that was
a brief introduction to the dfs
algorithm now for a better understanding
let's go through a practical example
so here we have a graph data structure
with elements a b
c
d
e and f so we will be running the dfs
algorithm and we will be traversing
through all the nodes of this particular
graph and the traversal will be recorded
using a stack data structure and we have
two different colors which will be used
to indicate the elements color
so the black color is for the nodes
which are not visited yet and the blue
color will indicate the nodes which are
being traversed already
now this is the stack data structure
that we will be using for the traversal
and we have another part which declares
or which gives out the output of the
traversal of the nodes of this
particular graph
now we will begin with the first one
that is a now followed by that we will
move ahead to b
then after b we will go through d
then after d we have e
next we have c and last we have f
so that's how we traverse through the
graph using the dfs algorithm
now for a little more understanding
let's go through a practical example
where we will be executing a program for
implementing the dfs algorithm
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for dfs algorithm so here
we have the structure node
so followed by that we have also the
methods which will create the edge
and which will also print the graph
elements and finally we have the main
class now don't worry about the code
this particular code segment or the
complete code document will be added in
the description box below and you can
have access to it and try to run it on
your local system and have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program and
get the output and see how the dfs
algorithm gets implemented and traverses
through the graph
there you go the program got
successfully executed and we had the
graph elements that is 0 1 and 2 and 3
so it has visited all the elements that
is 2 3 1 and 0 according to the
stack data structure and we have found
the output over here now let us try to
understand what exactly is searching
searching in data structure refers to
the process of finding the desired
element in the set of items the selected
item is called the target element any
data structure such as an array linked
list tree or graph can be used for
searching a set of elements
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two types first type is
the sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two ways the first type
is a sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
an example for sequential search is
linear search
now let us learn about the next type of
searching approach the next type of
searching approach is the interval
search approach
interval search divides the search in
half by repeatedly targeting the center
of the data set the binary search
algorithm can be an example for interval
search
we will go over the binary search
algorithm in detail in our upcoming
video
after understanding the logic of search
and the types of search we will get into
understanding what is linear search
algorithm
the linear search method is a simple
search technique in this type of
searching approach we perform a
sequential search across all objects one
after the other every element is
examined and if there is a match found
then the specific element is returned
otherwise the search will continue until
the data gathering is complete let us go
through an example for better learning
experience on my screen we have the
following elements 50 10 20 30 70 40 90
60 as randomly distributed elements let
us imagine that our target element is
70.
we found that our target element was 70
using linear search strategy so how does
it work in the next segment we will look
into the working terms of linear search
algorithm the simplest method of
searching the data collection is the
linear search starting from the
beginning of the data set each element
is examined until no match is found the
linear search is completed after the
item has located
in the first stage we compare the first
element that is 50 to the searched
element that is 70. we will go on to the
next element because 50 and 70 are not
matched
we will compare the second element which
is 10 to the search element that is 70
in the next step
and once more there is no match found
then we have the element 30 as the next
comparison and 70 and 30 are not matched
we have the next element that is 20 in
the fourth phase and there is no match
when we compare 20 with 70.
moving on to the following stage we have
the data element 70 and after comparing
70 with the search element there is a
match
we will now have the searching and
display index as 4 and this index
contains the searched element
we now comprehend the pseudo code of the
linear search algorithm after learning
the working terminology of linear search
algorithm
first we have a function called linear
search which has two variables in its
parameters the arrays name which is an
array and the search variable which is
the value
then using a follow we must search for
our target variable by analyzing all the
data elements in the data set with the
condition that is the search item is
identical to any sets value we must
return its index value
now we must stop searching once the
searched value has been discovered
then we will close our if and for loop
as well as the linear search function
we will now look into the complexity of
linear search algorithm after
comprehending the pseudo code
the complexity of linear search
algorithm is divided into three
categories the best case which is the
big o of one the average case which is
the big o of capital n and the worst
case scenario which is same as the
average case which is the big o of n
here n is the number of data items to be
sorted let us look into how all these
complexities of linear search algorithm
play out in detail
first we have the best case which is big
o of n as a result the best case
scenario happens when the searched
element is found in the data sets first
block
as a result the search takes a constant
amount of time
here is an example of an array with 50
10 40 20 30 as the elements
now our search element is 50 which is
located in the first location of the
array then there's the typical case of
linear search algorithm which has big o
of n and occurs when the search element
is in the middle of the data set or any
point of the data set with the array
containing the same search element 50 we
can easily see that the element 50 is
present in the center of the array at
the location number 2. finally we have
the worst case which is big o of n which
is same as that of the average case of
the linear search algorithm and happens
when the search element is in the last
block of the data set
as a result of the number of searches
required is proportional to the number
of elements as demonstrated in this
example the search element 50 is found
in the last block of the array index
which is 4.
in the next segment we will look into
some real-world instances of linear
search algorithms according to the first
application of the linear search
algorithm linear search is particularly
efficient when it comes to discovering a
particular string next we will look into
the second application of linear search
algorithm
when a data set has only few elements
linear search is the simplest to
implement
the final real world application of the
linear search algorithm is with the help
of telephone directory you may find out
the name of a person
with the phone number 123.
this can be implemented easily using
linear search algorithm now let us have
a look at the linear search algorithm
working in practical demonstration
so on my screen we have an example for
linear search algorithm we have included
three libraries standard input output
standard library and console input
output library
then we have entered the main function
where we have declared an array with
maximum size of 50 elements a counter
variable i a variable named target where
we would store our searched element and
finally num variable where the number of
elements in the array is recorded
then we have a printf function to ask
the user how many items are there in the
array and then we use a scanf function
to allow input from the keyboard so we
have added percentage d format specifier
to the scanner function which is used
for numeric values and num variable then
using a for loop we will try to print
all the items in the array starting with
0 and ending with num variable
which is the last element then we will
enter our search element which we want
to find among all the elements of the
array and as previously said we'll store
the found element in the target variable
following that we will use the for loop
to examine all the elements in the array
then we use the if statement to check
for the element is identical to our
searched element or not
if the element is found we exit the
follow and we will break the keyword
and if the target values location is
less than the number of elements in the
array then we will return the location
otherwise if the value location is
greater than the number of elements in
the array then the search will be
unsuccessful and we won't be able to
find the searched element now we will
compile this code and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled now it is asking
for the number of elements in the array
let me give us 5 elements now let us
enter the elements into the array let us
enter some random elements
now we have entered the 5 elements let
me provide the searched element as 2.
now we have found the target element to
be found in the location 2
that is 0 1 and 2 yeah 2 is located in
the second index location let's get
started with what exactly is a bucket
sort algorithm
so the bucket sort algorithm divides the
unsorted array into several groups known
as packets
so each packet is sorted using any
suitable sorting algorithm or
recursively applying the same packet
sort algorithm i know it it's a little
complicated to understand so let's go
through an example so on my screen we
have an example of an array consisting
of numerical elements that is 12 6 37 29
11 35 21 and 22.
now we will create some buckets with
different ranges
so here we have different buckets
ranging from 0 to 7
8 to 15 16 to 23 24 to 31 and finally
the last bucket with range 32 to 39
so 6 will be stored in the first packet
followed by that 11 and 12 will be
stored in the second bucket followed by
that we have 21 and 22 stored in the
third bucket followed by that we have 29
in the fourth bucket and finally the
last two elements which are 37 and 35
stored in the last bucket
in the next stage all the elements are
sorted according to an order that might
be ascending or descending in our case
we have the ascending order so the final
result will be 6 11 12 21 22 29 35 and
37
so this is how the bucket sort algorithm
works in real time now the next topic
that is working off a bucket sort
algorithm in a detailed way
so now we know the briefing of a
pakistan algorithm now let's learn the
working of packet sort algorithm in
depth
suppose we have an array consisting of
decimal values of floating values as the
input so the first element is 0.47
next we have 0.39 0.23
0.55 0.29 0.41
0.59 and finally
0.31
then we will create an array of size 10
and store 0 in each block
and each block of an array is used as a
bucket for sorting the elements
next we have step 2
insert the elements into buckets from
the array and all elements are inserted
as per the range of the bucket
packets ranging from 0 to 1
1 to 2
2 3 up to n minus 1 to n here n is the
number of elements in an array so for
our example 0.23 will be multiplied by
10 which is the size of an array and
that gives us 2.3 approximately equal to
2 so finally we will insert 0.23 into
the bucket number 2.
in exact we will insert other elements
into other respective buckets
followed by that we have step 3
elements of each bucket are sorted using
the stable sorting algorithms
and finally the step 4. in step 4 all
the sorted elements of each bucket will
be gathered and represented in the form
of an array as sudo code is an informal
programming description that does not
require any strict programming language
syntax similarly we will understand it
effortlessly
so in the pseudocode first we will
create n empty packets
next we will insert all the array
elements into buckets by multiplying the
size of an array we have to keep doing
this for every array element as we
understood this in working of the bucket
sort algorithm
after that we have to sort individual
buckets using insertion sort and finally
we will concatenate all the sorted
buckets next we will learn about the
complexities of bucket sort algorithm
first we will see about time complexity
so talking about the time complexity we
usually have three cases to summarize
the time complexity so first we have the
best case
so that the best case is o of n plus k
next we have the average case that is o
of n into n and finally we have the
worst case that is o of n
here n is the total number of elements
to be sorted and k is the number of
packets
so let us understand all the three cases
one by one so first we have the best
case
so the best case occurs when all the
elements are uniformly distributed in
the bucket with an equal number of
elements in each bucket if insertion
sort is used to sort the bucket sort
algorithm then overall time complexity
is o of n plus k
o of n complexity is for making the
buckets and of k complexity is for
sorting all the elements after
understanding the best case now we will
see how the worst case occurs in the
bucket sort algorithm
the worst case occurs when there are
elements of close range in the array
they are likely to be placed in the same
bucket
it makes the complexity depend on the
sorting algorithm used to sort the
elements of the buckets complexity
becomes worse when all the elements are
in reverse order and if insertion sort
is used for sorting then time complexity
becomes o of n into n
and lastly we will learn how the average
case occurs in a bucket sort algorithm
the average case occurs when the
elements are randomly distributed in the
array it occurs even when the elements
are distributed in uniform way bucket
sorts run at the linear time
the average case holds true until the
sum of bucket sort sizes is linear and
in the total number of elements
next we will see about the space
complexity
so the space complexity of all the
buckets algorithms is o of n plus k
lastly we have stability so talking
about stability so yes the bucket sort
algorithm is stable
after understanding the complexity of
packet sort algorithm now we will
compare the bucket sort algorithm with
other algorithms
so first we will compare the counting
sort algorithm
bucket sort can be worked as a
generalization of counting sort
algorithm and if each bucket has size 1
then the bucket sort degenerates to
counting zero
the variable size of buckets or
algorithm allows it to use o of n memory
instead of o of m memory where m stands
for the distinct value that gives
counting sort o of n plus one
worst case behavior
next we will compare the buckets or
algorithm with quick sort
bucket sort with two buckets is a
practical version of the quick sort
where the pivot value always selects the
median value of the value range another
meaning of choosing the pivot in quick
sort such as a randomly selected period
makes it more resistant to clustering it
in the input distribution
after that we have the merge sort the
n-way mercer algorithm starts by
distributing the list into n sub-list
and sorting each one then the sub-list
created by merge sort have overlapping
ranges and cannot be recombined by a
simple concatenation bucket sort
lastly we have one more sorting
algorithm that is radix sort for
comparison
top down radix sort can be a particular
case of bucket sort where both range of
values and the number of packets has
contained the power of two
this approach can accelerate the scatter
phase since we only need to examine each
element's prefix of bit representation
to determine a bucket
at last we have one more topic to learn
that is the applications of packet sort
algorithm
the bucket sort algorithm consists of
two main applications
first by using bucket set algorithm
input is uniformly distributed on the
range and second by using bucket sort
algorithm there are floating point
values
now let us go through a practical
demonstration of bucket sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
packet sort algorithm so we will begin
with the header files followed by that
we will define a function namely bucket
sort algo
this particular function is to implement
a bucket sort algorithm in the functions
argument there will be an array namely
arr and a variable num which will store
the number of elements in an array after
that we will define two counter
variables which are i and j and declare
one more array namely array1 with the
same size of an arr array
so this particular second array will be
used for displaying all the elements in
the array1 we will have a for loop which
will run from index 0 to the entire size
of an array and for this array we will
use the variable i as the counter
variable
we will have another for loop to print
all the repeated numbers with frequency
in an array
we will run another follow from index 0
to the last element of both the arrays
and elements of array and array 1 will
assign to arr array
now we will execute from both the loops
and now we will enter into the main
function where we will declare an array
namely array with the size of 100 and
two variables which are num and i
next we will ask the user to enter
several elements of an array using
printf function
and now the user will enter
number of elements and we will scan that
using the scanf function
now we will ask the user to enter the
elements of an array using printf
function and the entered elements will
be scanned using the scanf function
and next we will print a before sorting
and an array after sorting using for
loops by calling the packet sotilgo
function and in this function we will
pass the name of an array that is an
array and the size of an array that is
num
now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let us try to
enter the number of elements that is
five now let us enter all the five
elements
two three
one four and five
so the array before sorting was two
three one and four five then the array
got sorted using packet sort algorithm
and the resultant array is one two three
four and five in ascending order
counting sort is a sorting algorithm
that sorts the elements of an array by
counting the number of occurrence of
each unique element in the array the
count is stored in an auxiliary array
and the sorting is done by mapping the
count as an index of that auxiliary
error
now let's discuss the counting sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in this array to evaluate the range of
the elements
then we will create a count array to
store the count of element from the
array
then we will update the count arrays
element with a cumulative count
at last
we will output each element from the
array followed by decreasing its count
by 1.
we have now introduced the counting sort
and its algorithm
now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor
let's start by creating account sort
function
void
count sort
its argument as int arr
comma
and
n
we will declare an array
output
size 10
and an array count
again with the size 10
and an integer variable
max
is equals to arr at 0.
now we will write a for loop to find the
largest element of this array
so for
and i is equals to 1
i less than n
i plus plus
if
arr at i
is greater than max
and max
will be equals to
arr
at i
now we will initialize the count array
with all zeros so for
end i is equals to zero
to i less than equals to max
s plus i
count
at i
is equals to zero
now we will store the count of each
element in this array so for loop
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
count
at arr bracket i
is plus plus
now we will write a for loop to store
the cumulative count of each array so
for
and
i is equals to
1
where i is less than equals to max
at i plus plus
count
at i
is equals to
plus equals to
count
at i
minus 1
now we will find the index of each
element of the original array in count
error and place the elements in the
output array
so for
and
i is equals to n
minus 1
i
greater than equals to
0. i minus minus
so output
at arr
i
minus
1
is equals to
arr
at i
and
then we will decrease count
arr
i
by one
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
print array
so end
arr bracket
comma end
n
so for loop
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
c out
arr
at i
handle
now let's write the main block
and
arr
is equals to
we will write the element
now let's find out the size of this
array so end n is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
that is first element
now we will call the count sort function
arr comma
n
now we will print this array so print
array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using counting sort
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up counting sort is not an
comparison based sorting algorithm
next up it is frequently used as
subroutine in other sorting algorithms
such as radix sort
next up counting sort can be performed
only on positive integers
finally counting sort utilizes a partial
hashing to calculate the data item
occurrence in big o of one let's get
started with an introduction to radix
sort
radix sort is a non-comparative sorting
algorithm it avoids comparison by
creating and distributing elements into
buckets according to their radix
and for elements with more than one
significant digit this bucketing process
is repeated for each digit while
preserving
the ordering of the prior step until all
digits have been considered
now let's discuss radix sort algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in the array to decide maximum number of
significant digits we will need to
compare to sort this array
we will go through each significant
place and sort the array one by one
first we will sort the array according
to the units place
then we will sort according to the tens
place
and then we will sort according to
hundreds place and so on till the array
is sorted
we have now introduced the radix sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start with the utility function
to get maximum value in this array
so int
get max
with an argument as array arr
comma size
n
we will declare variable int mx is
equals to arr at 0
and we will write a for loop
where
i is equals to 1
to i less than n
at i plus plus
if
arr at i
is greater than mx
then
mx will be equals to arr
at i
and then we will return
the value of mx
now we will write a function to do
counting sort of array arr according to
the digits represented by exponent
so void
exp
we will declare an integer array output
and
i
comma
account array
of size 10
where all elements are 0.
now we will store the count of all the
elements of the array arr
so for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than n
to i plus plus
count
error
at i
divided by
exp
modulus of
10
plus plus
now we will change count i so that
count i now contain actual position of
this digit in output
so for
i is equals to 1
i less than 10
i plus plus
count
i
plus equals to
count
i minus 1.
now we will build the output array
so for loop
at i is equals to n minus 1
to i greater than equals to zero
and i minus minus
output
round
arr
at i
divided by exp
modulus
10.
minus 1
is equals to
arr at i
and now
count
arr
at i
divided by exp
modular
10
minus minus
now we will copy the output array of arr
so that arr now contains sorted numbers
according to the current digit
so for
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
error
at i
is equals to
output
now let's write the mean function that
will sort the arr using radix sort
so void
red x
sort
and arr
comma
and
and
n
now we will do the counting sort for
every digit note that instead of passing
digit number exp is passed exp is
basically 10 raised to the power i
where i is current digit number
so
for
exp is equals to one
and m divided by
exp
is greater than zero
while exp
is multiplied equals to
10
we will do count sort
on arr
of size n
with exp
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
and array
and arr
comma
and
n
for
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
layout
array
now let's write the main function
we will declare
end arr
bracket
with values
170 comma 45 comma 75
comma
90
comma
802
comma 24
comma 2
comma
66
now we will find out the size of this
array arr
and
is equals to size of
arr
divided by
size of
arr first element
now we will call the radix sort function
and we will print this array
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using radix sort
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up radix sort can be used on
lexographically sortable data
next up radix sort utilizes the count
sort algorithm
next radix sort is done by sorting
elements using significant digits
finally radix sort consumes more memory
space than quick sort let's get started
with what is a binary heap
it's a complete binary tree with all
levels completely filled except the last
level
where all leaves are to the left as far
as possible
a binary heap can be either min heap or
maxi
in a min binary heap the elements at
root must be minimum among all elements
present in the binary heap
max binary heap is like min heap where
root must be maximum among all elements
now let's discuss implementation of heap
sort
first
we will start with creating a max heap
of elements present
next up we will remove the elements at
the root and put it at the end of the
array and put the smallest element at
the root
after that we will reduce the height by
1.
finally we will repeify the root element
again and repeat the process from step
2. now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor we will
start by creating a function to epify a
subtree rooted with node i which is an
index in array arr
and n is the size of the heap
so void
heapify
and
arr
comma end n
comma
end
it
now we will initialize largest as root
so end
largest
is equals to i
now we will define the left and the
right subtree so end
l is equals to
2
into i
plus 1
and
end
r is equals to
2 multiply
with i
plus 2
now if the left child is larger than
root
then
if l is less than n
and
arr
at l
error at l is greater than arr
at largest
so the largest
will be equals to l
now if
right child is larger than the largest
so far
so if
r is less than n
and
arr at r
is greater than arr
at largest
so largest
is equals to r
now if largest is not root so if
largest
is not equals to i
we will swap
arr
at i
with
a arr
at largest
and then we will recursively call ep5
for the affected subtree
here are comma
and
comma largest
now we will write the main function to
do heap sort
so void
keep sort
and
arr
bracket comma
and
n
now we will start by building heap
so far
and
i is equals to
n by 2
minus 1
where
i is greater than equals to 0
at i minus
minus we will call heapify
for arr comma n comma i
now we will one by one extract an
element from the heap
so for
and i
is equals to n minus one
where i is greater than zero
at i minus minus
now we will move current root to end so
swap
error
at zero
to arr
at i
and we will call max apify on the
reduced heap so
pie
error
comma i
comma
zero
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
print array
arr
comma and n
so far
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
plus plus i
we will do c out
arr
bracket i
face
and a c
out and l
now let's write the code for the main
block
so
end
arr
is equals to
e comma
18 comma 12
comma
14 comma
5 comma 6
comma
2.
now we will write a statement to find
the size of this array
so end
and it's equals to
size of
arr
divided by
size of
the first element of the array
arr0
now we will call heap sort function so
heap sort
for arr
comma n
now let's print this
array
so c out
sorted
array
is
print
array
at ar comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see our sorting function is
working flawlessly
now let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed the binary
heap and the algorithm of heapsort
now let's discuss some applications of
heap salt
first up
it can be used to sort a nearly sorted
series of data
next it can be used to find minimum or
maximum elements of the series with ease
also it can be used to solve problems
which requires some sort of priority
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up
the tank complexity of heap sort is big
o of
n log n
next heap sort is good at easily finding
the smallest or largest element in a
heap
next there is no additional memory space
required to execute this algorithm
finally a heap sort is basically used
for problems based on the priority
queues
in this session we will learn about
merge sort in data structures what
exactly is divide and conquer algorithm
a divide and conquer algorithm
iteratively divides a problem into two
or more sub problems of the same or
relative type until they are simple
enough to be solved directly the sub
problem solutions are then integrated to
solve the original problem
there are three steps involved in the
divide and conquer principle that is
divide
conquer and combine
the first step is to divide the
significant problem into smaller sub
problems
second phase is to conquer the solutions
to all divided sub problems then the
final step is to combine and merge all
of the solutions to create a definite
solution
we will understand this by an example
right here on my screen
suppose we have a large problem we can
use divide and conquer technique to
divide it into n number of sub problems
such as problem 1 problem 2 problem 3
problem 4 and so on until we reach the
problem n
then we conquer all the solutions to the
specified sub problems as solution 1 2 3
4 and so on and finally we merge all the
solutions to get one definitive solution
now that was divide and conquer
algorithm followed by that let us get
into merge sort algorithm
so merge sort is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithms it is based
on divide and conquer strategy merge
sort continuously divides a list into
numerous sub-list until each sub-list
contains only one entry then merges all
those sub-list into a sorted list
there are four elements on my screen
we have seven and three in the left half
and five and two in the right half after
dividing the four elements in half we
combined all the items in ascending
order that is 2 3 5 and 7.
in the next segment we are going to
understand how it happened and we are
going to learn the working procedure of
merge sort algorithm
there are two approaches to implement
the merge sort algorithm the first
method is top-down approach and the
second method is bottom-up approach the
first method that is the top-down
approach implies that it begins with the
large picture from then it's broken into
smaller chunks
now the second method that is the
bottom-up technique which starts with a
specific number of jobs and works its
way up to the general
let's have a look at how to implement
the merge sort algorithm using top-down
approach the top-down merge sort
approach is the methodology that uses a
recursion mechanism it starts at the top
and proceeds downwards splitting the
array into two halves making a recursive
call and merging the results until one
gets to the bottom of the array for a
better understanding of the top down
approach method
consider the following scenario right
here on my screen we have an example of
an array of size 6 consisting of
elements 7 3 9 5 6 and 4 starting with 0
and ending with 5.
using the following formula we'll divide
the array by its middle that is middle
is equals to left plus right divided by
two
we have three elements on the left and
three elements on the right near the
middle so according to the drop down
strategy we divide the given array in
half resulting in three elements that is
7 3 and 9 on the left and 5 6 and 4 on
the right next we sort all these
elements in ascending order by doing so
the first half will be 3 7 and 9 and the
right half will be 4 5 and 6 and after
merging all of them we will have the
sorted array that is 3 4 5 6 and 9.
next we will understand the bottoms up
approach
an iterative process is used in bottoms
up merge sort approach it starts with a
single element array and then joins two
neighboring items while also sorting
them the combined sorted arrays are
combined and sorted again only until one
single unit of the sorted array elements
remains
now let us look at an example right here
on my screen in the first iteration we
will merge pairs of array sizes by 1
sorting each of the 2 elements
when you iterate the array by size 1 the
elements 7 and 3 become 3 and 7
similarly 9 and 5 become 5 and 9 and
finally 6 and 4 become 4 and 6
we will merge the pairs of array size by
2 in the next iteration with the bottoms
up method as a result the elements 3 7
and 5 will become 3 5 and 7 and the same
way 9 4 and 6 will become 4 6 and 9.
in the last iteration merge pairs of
array size by 3 so that after sorting 3
5 7 4 6 and 9 becomes 3 4 5 6 and 7 as
sorted arrays
after understanding the working
procedure of merge sort algorithm we
will now see the pseudo code of merge
sort algorithm
we have a function called merge sort in
this pseudo code and parameter of the
function contains an array named as
array and two variables named as left
and right
if the number of elements in the left is
greater than the number of elements on
the right we will get a middle using
formula left plus right divided by 2.
the merge sort is called and this
function
now has an array a left variable and
right variable by calling merge sort we
have array left as middle plus
one and right variable and finally by
calling merge sort we have left middle
and right variables in our upcoming
segment we will implement the merge sort
method in a practical demonstration
in the next section we will discuss the
complexity of merge sort algorithm
first we will look into the time
complexity of merge sort algorithm as we
all know time complexity in data
structures is divided into best case
average case and worst case the best
case of merced algorithm is big o of n
into log n average case of merced
algorithm is big o of n into log n and
the worst case of merced algorithm is
big o of n into log n
the number of elements being sorted is
given by n
merge sorts time complexity is big o of
n star log n in all three situations
that has first average and best because
it always divides the array into two
halves and merges the two halves in
linear time
it takes up the same amount of space as
the unsorted array as a result it is not
a good idea to use it to search big
unsorted arrays moving on to the space
complexity of the merced algorithm the
space complexity of the merge sort
algorithm is large o of n
in the merced algorithm we store the
left and right parts of the merged array
in the temporary arrays and then utilize
the original array to keep the entire
merged array in the worst case scenario
the left and the right sub arrays will
each be n by 2 in size and then the
total auxiliary space will be big o of n
resulting in a space complexity of big o
of n
following that we will look into several
applications of the merge sort algorithm
so the first application is merge sort
is an efficient way to sort link list in
big o of n log n time
subsequent application of the merchant
algorithm is for linked lists
merge sort implemented without taking up
more space followed by that the mozart
method is used to count the number of
inversions in a list
last application states that in internal
sorting the merge sort is employed
now let us look into some of the
drawbacks of merge sort algorithm
so some of the drawbacks of merchant
algorithm are for smaller assignments
merge sort algorithm is slower than the
other sorting algorithms for temporary
array the merge sort technique requires
an additional memory space that is space
of big o of n
now let us look into a practical
demonstration of merge sort algorithm on
my screen we have an example for merge
sort algorithm
to define constants or microsubstitution
we use the hash defined as preprocessor
directive with a constant variable max
of 10. following that two arrays array 1
and array 2 are declared we declare
array 1 and initialize it with elements
like 8
9 10
4 and 1.
array 2 is used for temporary array then
to implement the merge sort concept we
declare a merge sort function we specify
three variables in this function
parameter that is left right and middle
the left variable is used to display the
left part of the array1 the right
variable is used to display the right
part of the array1 and middle variable
is used to indicate the middle or center
of the array in this function
we utilize the for loop in this function
setting the left 2 level 1 the middle
plus 1 to level 2 and
the left to variable i with the
condition that level 2 is less than or
equal to the middle and level 2 should
be less than or equal to the right of
the array we have a condition in this
for loop that if level 1 of array 1 is
less than or equal to level 2 of array 1
we will initialize all the consecutive
elements of level 1 of array 1 to array
2. else we will initialize all the
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 to array 2.
out of for loop all subsequent elements
of level 1 of array 1 will be
initialized to array 2 until level 1 is
less than or equal to the middle all
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 will be initialized to array 2 until
level 2 is less than or equal to the
right of the array
using the loop which will run from i
equal to
the left of i is less than or equal to
right we initialize all the items of
array 2 to array 1. we have declared one
more function in this code namely
sorting out of the merging sort function
in which only the left and right
variables are defined we specified the
middle function in the sorting function
with the condition that if the left is
less than the right the middle will be
calculated as left plus right divided by
2. then we call the sorting function
passing left as middle as right and then
another sorting function passing left as
middle plus 1 and right
finally we use the merge sort function
passing left middle and right to the
sorting array 1 otherwise we would
return nothing
we entered the main function out of the
sorting function where we declared the
counter variable i and printed the array
before sorting using the printf function
in for loop where i will run from index
0 to the array's maximum size after that
we invoked sorting method
passing left as 0 index number and write
as the iris maximum value finally after
doing the merge sort process we will
print the array using the printf
function and for loop
we will run
from 0 to the array's maximum value then
we compile the program and run it
now let's try to quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the list
before sorting is eight seven six two
three five nine ten four and one and the
list after sorting is one two three four
four five six seven eight nine and ten
in this session we will discuss quick
sort a quick sort is a highly efficient
sorting algorithm and it is based on
partitioning an array into smaller sub
arrays and then we will sort these two
resulting sub arrays in the same manner
this algorithm is quite efficient for
large size data sets as its average and
worst case complexities are big o of n
square
now let's discuss algorithm of quick
sort
let's say we have an array first we have
to select a pivot
we can select either the first element
or the last or medium or any random
element as pivots this pivot will
dissect the array into two sub-arrays
then we will shift all smaller elements
than the pivot element to the left
then we will again apply the same
operation for the left sub array and
take pivot like we did for the main
array
we will perform the same for the right
sub array as well
we have now introduced the quick sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
so void swap
int
star
x
comma
end
star x
star x is equals to star y
ry is equals to temp
now we will write a function which will
partition this array this function will
take the last element as pivot
and the pivot element at its correct
position in sorted array and places all
smaller elements
to the left of the pivot and all greater
elements to the right of the pivot
so int
partition
and
arr
comma
end
low
comma
and i
so end
pivot
equals to
ar high
now end
i
is equals to
low minus 1
so for
end
j is equals to low
j less than equals to high minus 1
a plus plus
now if current element is smaller than
the pivot
so if
here at j
is less than pivot
then we will increment the i
then we will swap
ampersand array
i
comma
ampersand array
at j
then we will
swap ampersand
array
at i plus 1
comma
10
array
at high
and then we will return
i plus one
now we will write the main function that
implements quick sort
so void
quick sort
and
arr
bracket
comma and low
comma and high
so if
o
is less than high
and
p i
is equals to partition
arr comma
low
comma
hi
now we will separately sort elements
before partition and after partition
so
quick sort
arr comma
low
comma
pi minus 1
and
quick sort
arr
comma
bi
plus 1
comma i
now we will write a function to print
this array
so
void
and
array
and
arr
comma
end
size
and
high
so for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than size
i plus plus
see out
array
at it
layout
and
now we will write the main block so end
array
and comma 7
comma eight
i will find the size so int n
is equals to
size of
array
is divided by
size of
array
element at zero
now we will call quick sort
n minus one
now we will print this
so c out
sorted
array
a print
eric
arr command
now let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted our array
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up quick sort follows the divide
and conquer principle next up quick sort
has an average space and time complexity
of big o of n log n
next all pivots should be selected in
the same manner as the first pivot
finally quick sort is an unstable
sorting algorithm
so even a single mistake can crash a
program
let's get started with an introduction
to selection sort
the selection sort algorithm is an
in-place comparison based method that
divides the list into two halves with
the sorted portion on the left and the
unsorted half on the right
then the smallest element from the
unsorted array is chosen and swapped
with the leftmost element and that
element is added to the sorted error
now let's discuss the selection sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will divide this array in two
sub-arrays unsorted array and sorted
array
then we will divide the minimum element
from the unsorted array and swap it with
the leftmost element of this unsorted
array after that we will add it to the
unsorted array
we will keep repeating this process
until there are no elements left on the
unsorted array
we have now introduced
selection sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
argument will be integer pointer
x
comma
integer pointer
y
we will declare an element temp
to store the value of
pointer x
then we will store pointer wise value in
x
and we will store temps value in y
and that's how we can swap them
next we will write the definition of
selection sort function
void
selection sort
argument will be
end
array arr
comma
and
n
we will declare variables end i
j
and a min
underscore idx
variable to store the minimum index
now we will one by one move boundaries
of unsorted sub arrays
so for loop
i is equals to zero
where i is less than n minus one
i plus plus
we will find the minimum element in this
unsorted array so
min
underscore
idx
is equals to i
up for
a is equals to
i plus one
j less than n
j plus plus
if
error element at jth location
is less than
array at the min index
then
min idx
will be updated with j
now we will swap the form minimum
element with the first element
so
we will call swap function
with argument as
ampersand
arr
at min idx
comma
ampersand
arr
at ith location
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
print
array argument as int arr
and its size
and n
for loop
and i is equals to zero
i less than
n
i plus plus
v out
arr
at i
now we will write the code for the main
block
so end
arr
is equals to
4 comma 2 comma 1 comma a comma 3
we will find the size of this array so
end n is equals to
size of
array arr
divided by
size of
this arrays first element
now we will call selection sort function
argument as arr comma n
then we will try to print this so see
out
sorted
array
and we will call the function print
array
to print this array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using selection sort
algorithm
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up the selection sort algorithm is
a comparison based in-place algorithm
next the selection sort algorithm is not
appropriate for use data sets
next up selection sort have the worst
complexity of big o of n square
finally it can be beneficial when memory
write is an expensive procedure in this
session we will discuss shell sort shell
sort is a sorting algorithm that is
based on insertion sort algorithm and it
is very efficient when the smaller value
is on the far right and must be shifted
to the far left then this method avoids
significant shifts as in insertion sort
now let's discuss the algorithm of shell
sort
let's say we have an array we will
initialize a variable h
this edge will represent intervals
then we will divide this array into h
intervals
it will create sub sub arrays
then we will apply insertion sort on
these sub arrays
after that we will reduce the interval
edge by one
then we will repeat this process
recursively until h counts down to one
we have now introduced shell sort and
its algorithm now let's try to implement
this algorithm in the code editor
first we will start within function to
sort an array using shell sort
so in
cell sort
we will write argument as int
arr
bracket
comma
and n
will start within big interval then we
will reduce this interval by 1
so
for loop
and
interval
equals to n by two
interval
greater than zero
interval
divide equals to two
now we will do a gap insertion sort for
this interval
so for
and i is equals to interval
i is less than n
i plus equals to 1
and
amp
is equals to
arr bracket i
now we will shift earlier gap sorted
element up until the correct location
for arr i is for
so hint
a
so for
k is equals to i
and j greater than equals to interval
and then
arr bracket
j minus interval
greater than temp
and j minus equals to
interval
j minus
interval
now we will put this stamp in its
correct location so arr
bracket j
is equals to
temp
now i will return zero
now let's write a function to print this
array
so void
print
array
and
error
comma
and
n
so for loop
and
j is equals to zero
a less than
n
j plus plus
c out
arr
bracket j
now we will write the function for the
main block
so int
arr
is equals to
12 comma 34
comma
56 comma
85 comma
2 comma
9
comma 11
comma
5.
now
let's find the size for this array so
int n
is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
first element of this array
now
see out
array
array
before
sort
now print
array
cell sort
error
comma n
now see out
erase
after
sorting
we will again print array
here comma m
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted
this array
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session first up shelf
sort has higher cash miss ratio
than quicksort
next shell sort is helpful when small
elements are to the farther right
next shell sort utilizes insertion sort
algorithm
finally shell sort requires fewer swaps
than
insertion sort choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's get started with the real-life
example of greedy algorithm in order to
understand it better this is alex he's
quite wealthy and intelligent as he
works for one of the most reputed it
firms
and this is alex's best friend rachel
rachel is in dire need of 85 right now
however she needs money in such a
quantity that the number of coins is
kept to a minimum so rachel shared this
issue with alex and asked him for help
now alex is thinking about rachel's
issue which he can easily fix because he
has a limitless supply of fifty dollars
twenty dollars ten dollars and five
dollar coins stashed in various bags
although this being said alex needed to
think about the constraint rachel told
him about he needed to give her money
such that the number of coins utilized
must be minimal to do so alex began
making a list of the various coin
combinations in which he could present
money to rachel however after a while he
became confused due to the vast number
of conceivable combinations
so he decided to use his programming
ability to solve real life problems
alex developed a program that will
provide him with the optimal number of
coins that he can present to rachel
this generated program was iterating
through the different possibilities to
choose the best solution
at each iteration the program added the
coin of the largest value that was not
taking alex past the amount to be paid
which is 85 dollars in this case
for 85 dollars the largest denomination
id can start giving is 50
now id is still short of 35 to reach the
amount so that the next largest coin
program can take in as 20
but since the program still requires 15
to meet the threshold the next highest
denomination it can accept is ten
dollars followed by five dollars
the best part about this program was
that it allowed alex to present eighty
five dollars in just four coins which is
fairly incredible
the vital thing to note here is that
after each loop the program makes a
greedy choice providing the coin with
the highest potential value what i mean
here by greedy is that locally optimal
choice is picked at every step to reach
the global optimum solution now moving
ahead we will formulate the idea of
greedy algorithms
basically a greedy algorithm is based on
a problem solving method that involves
making locally optimal decisions at each
stage in the hopes of achieving a global
optimum
that means at each stage we choose a
locally optimal value in the hopes of
arriving at the optimum possible end
result
furthermore this algorithm is an
optimization technique that can find
either minimum optimum result or maximum
optimum result
the best part about this algorithm is
that it is simple to understand and
implement as well additionally the
runtime complexity for this algorithm is
pretty reasonable however the
fundamental disadvantage of this
strategy is that we only receive the
globally optimum value in a small
percentage of cases
having said that you must be thinking
about when to implement this algorithm
for solving particular problems as it
does not always produce globally optimum
results
well let me tell you guys that we have
two conditions to judge our problem for
implementing greedy algorithms
the first condition is the greedy choice
property
this notion states that making locally
optimal judgments can lead to the global
optimum solution for a given problem
the second condition is about optimal
substructure
the problem has an optimal substructure
only if an optimal solution to the
entire problem comprises the optimal
solutions to the sub-problems
in simpler words that means the problem
can be split down into multiple
sub-problems and the solutions to these
sub problems can collectively lead to a
solution for the entire problem
if both the above mentioned properties
are satisfied by the problem then we can
create a greedy solution for that
particular problem
moving forward we will look into the
steps for constructing a greedy solution
finding the substructure or sub-problem
that can lead us to the final answer is
the first step in building a greedy
algorithm
because in this algorithm we are just
trying to operate with local optima to
reach the global optimum solution
the second step is about determining the
type of solution the given problem can
result into that can be either the
largest sum or minimum path
the final step for creating the greedy
solution is about creating an iterative
process for traversing through local
stages and making decisions to reach a
globally optimum solution
now you might be confused about how we
can do that
well let's go through an example to
understand the approach to implement a
greedy solution
the example that we are going to deal
with is called the traveling salesman
problem in which a salesman is supposed
to reach the destination from a given
current location
the representation of cities and parts
connecting them is done using graph
structure that each node is considered
as a city and edges connecting them as
parts having edge weight as the distance
between the two cities
now in this case we are supposed to find
the minimum path between two cities so
to do that we will begin from the
current arbitrary position
from this node called as starting
location there are three possible paths
but the path towards city b has less
distance hence we will traverse this
edge primarily as it is an optimal local
route
we have reached city b now and from this
node we have two possible parts out of
which one part directly leads us towards
the destination city having distance 20
but the other path leading towards the
city f has edge weight value or distance
value as 2.
hence according to the local optimal
decision we will choose the edge
connecting cities b and f for traversal
we have reached the city f now from this
noro city there is only one path leading
us to our destination
hence we will traverse it now we have
reached the destination city the path
highlighted in the green shade is the
global optimum for this tsp problem you
can verify that by calculating the edge
weights for all other possible parts
since the solution allows us to reach
the global optimum by making optimal
decisions at the local stage this
strategy to solve the problem will be
considered a greedy approach
now moving ahead we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithm
we have learnt that the greedy algorithm
makes decisions based on local optimum
instead of analyzing the broader picture
of the whole data hence there is a
possibility that the greedy solution
might not be the best optimal solution
for some problems
for example consider this travelling
salesman problem
in this problem the highlighted part is
a created solution to reach the
destination city from the current
location using a greedy algorithm
but if you observe this graph the
selected solution is not the global
optimal solution for this problem
in contrast it is the worst generated
solution to reach the destination
that is why the greedy algorithm is
considered to be prone to correctness
issues
even if the algorithm is correct proving
why it is correct is difficult thus it
is deemed to be trickier to solve
specific issues
now we will discuss about applications
of greedy algorithms to understand their
importance
the first application of a greedy
algorithm is its use for constructing
minimum spanning trees
the coring approaches that we use to
generate msds is based on the greedy
algorithm
both prim's algorithm and crystal's
algorithm are known as greedy algorithms
as they make decisions based on locally
optimal decisions
the next application of the greedy
algorithm is its used to implement
huffman encoding and decoding algorithms
the huffman coding technique is a
lossless data compression method
the concept is to give variable length
codes to input characters the lengths of
which are determined by the frequency of
the related characters
the smallest code is assigned to the
most frequently occurring character
whereas the largest code is assigned to
the least frequently occurring character
this process is carried out by making
local optimum decisions
hence it is also considered to be a
greedy algorithm
the final application of the greedy
algorithm is its use for developing
solutions to well-known coding problems
those problems are the activity
selection problem job selection problem
and fractional knapsack problem
all these problems generate solutions by
making decisions at each local stage so
the solutions for these problems can be
developed quite easily using the greedy
approach
so these were the sorting algorithms
discussed in this particular session if
you have any queries regarding any of
the sorting algorithms or if you need
the code that we executed in this
particular tutorial then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
sections below and our team of experts
will be happy to solve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning